[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires sur tv5
monde en direct et avec nos partenaires
ouest france nice-matin france antilles
la montagne et 20 minutes et vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en live sur les
sites internet en numérique de nos
partenaires et également en rediffusion
vous le savez le samedi matin
voilà mes deux invités aujourd'hui bien
ce sont deux analystes de la vie
politique française bonjour bruno
cautrès dont jouit le chercheur au cnrs
au cevipof et vous êtes enseignant à
sciences politiques et bonjour hervé
gattegno vous êtes éditorialiste au
point et à l'opinion et vous êtes
l'excellent ancien patron de paris match
et du jdd merci d'être avec nous ce
matin une émission consacrée à elisabeth
borde la première ministre française
elle a été nommée vous le savez par
emmanuel macron sa dernière grande
émission politique eh bien c'était ici
chez nous ici même à face aux
territoires c'était le 10 février
dernier elle était notre invité écouter
ce qu'elle a déclaré sur sa relation
avec ségolène royal est-ce que vous avez
des nouvelles de ségolène royal dont
vous avez dirigé le cabinet nouvelle pas
pouvoir donner vous ne venez pas de
contacts n'ont même pas vraiment de
contacts non je pense qu'on n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord sur beaucoup de
sujets bruno cautrès faire gattegno donc
les contacts sont rompues ça mérite de
la franchise effectivement comme
dégradation alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on voit elisabeth bord qui que
ça amuse aussi votre votre question et
villefranche saurait les en tranches et
voilà les franches visiblement leurs
relations de travail puisque les
abeilles bonne à travailler sous
l'autorité de ségolène royal n'a pas dû
c'est beaucoup de bons souvenirs c'est
une femme tranche oui c'est une femme
franche une femme franche directe qui
dit les choses et là on était avec votre
question et sa réponse ont été
directement au coeur du sujet de
l'équation politique d'elisabeth borg
est ce qu'elle est vraiment temps à
gauche à l'esa ce qu'on va parce qu'elle
a été nommée pour séduire la gauche tant
que ça on sait pas au passage dans
certaines émissions depuis sa nomination
ségolène royal a dit elle qu' elle était
intervenue pour faire nommer elizabeth
bande à la ratp à la tête de la ratp ce
qui s'est réellement fait mais elle a
refusé de dire que c'était un bon choix
elle a dit ça on verra ça dépend d'elle
c'est bruno cautrès et hervé gattegno
nos invités analyste politique ce matin
pour revenir sur la nomination
d'elizabeth borne à matignon notre
partenaire du groupe centre france la
montagne
alex ans de charrier ce matin qui est
journaliste à la république du centre à
une question à poser à bruno cautrès
depuis orléans relais coûte
13 bonjour il y avait le borgne a
finalement un profil assez proche de
celui de jean castex l'un était issu des
rangs de la sarkozie la nouvelle
première ministre elle a fait ses
classes dans lesquelles une et
mystérieux de la gauche socialiste mais
après cinq années de présence au
gouvernement où est leur apporter des
réformes comme celles de l'assurance
chômage ou de l'ouverture de la
concurrence à la sncf est ce que
finalement c'est elle qui a le meilleur
profil pour donner des gages aux
électeurs de gauche d'une inflexion de
la politique d' emmanuel macron pour ces
cinq années à venir c'est la vraie
question
question importante effectivement est-ce
qu'elle a le meilleur profil je suis pas
sûr qu'elle ait le meilleur profil pour
envoyer des signaux à une partie assez
l'art de l'électorat de la gauche qui a
reçu beaucoup de grosses inona part de
jean luc mélenchon depuis quelques
semaines elisabeth bornes on dit qu'elle
vient du centre gauche qu'elle a une
sensibilité aux questions de l'égalité
des chances donc des problématiques qui
sont importantes pour l'électorat de 200
kg au centre gauche mais effectivement à
la portée des réformes qui ne sont pas
vraiment de centre gauche au cours des
cinq dernières années donc ça c'est la
question importante pour l comment elle
va incarner auprès des électeurs de
centre gauche la question de l'égalité
des chances la question de la
redistribution
j'imagine qu'elle va devoir prendre des
décisions assez forte sur le pouvoir
d'achat en particulier très attendu sur
cette question tout de suite
françois-xavier l'offrant le rédacteur
en chef de ouest france est avec nous et
ils rendent sur ce plateau à tout petit
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier le franc vous
êtes le rédacteur en chef du plus grand
quotidien francophone du monde oui
bonjour bonjour jour et nous allons donc
revenir sur la nomination des deux
bornes avec nous et nous deux invités le
10 février dernier elle était donc la
nouvelle premier ministre notre invitée
elle était à l'époque ministre du
travail et elle était interrogée sur ce
plateau pour sur son action pour
endiguer le chômage et la précarité chez
les jeunes vous allez voir ce qu'elle a
répondu c'est l'un des objectifs de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui est à
la fois de favoriser le travail en
s'assurant que c'est toujours plus
intéressant de travailler que d'être au
chômage je pense que ça paraît de bon
sens mais ce n'était pas le cas
précédemment
et puis on a aussi mis en place un
système de bonus malus pour encourager
précisément les entreprises à proposer
des contrats de travail plus long je
pense que c'est aussi l'intérêt de tout
le monde ça permet de travailler
davantage et ça évite effectivement la
précarité
alors les jeunes le chômage et la
précarité une question importante quand
elle a été nommée on a dit et elle
technocrates pas technocrates ce qui de
mon point de vue est complètement idiot
quand une personnalité rentrer à
matignon quelle qu'elle soit lancée
l'hypothétique technocrates août c'est
pas pour faire des parties de claquettes
c'est pour bosser alors at elle été une
bonne ministre at elle été une bonne
ministre at elle été efficace sur la
question des jeunes qui est évidemment
centrale elle a eu des résultats les
chiffres de l'apprentissage en fortement
se sont fortement améliorés de façon
même très spectaculaire alors je vous
pose la question vaut donc aux tresses
at elle été une bonne ministre parce que
c'est pas rien elle devient premier
ministre est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est une bonne ministre qui devient
première ministre il ya donc qui arrive
avec un fort potentiel tous ceux qui ont
travaillé avec elle ou qui se sont
affrontés elles reconnaissent tous sont
extrêmes maîtrise des dossiers que c'est
justement pas une partie simple quand on
a affaire à elle parce qu'elle attend
que la partie d'en face y compris si on
s'oppose elle maîtrise aussi bien les
deux séquelles dont visiblement c'est
quelqu'un qui bosse beaucoup c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît bien les dossiers
vous avez raison quand on est à matignon
c'est sinéquanone on n'attend pas que le
premier ministre n'a matters
doit être au contraire quelqu'un qui
fait tourner la machine de l'état jean
castex edouard philippe avait pleinement
se profile elle elle vient aussi à la
multiple et expériences dans les
cabinets ministériels elle est passée
par la préfectorale donc normalement
elle va savoir faire tourner la machine
de l'état est faut toujours rappeler que
les français quelles que soient les
décisions qui sont prises ils ont une
exigence d'efficacité
ils en ont assez quand leur annonce des
réformes des changements et puis au fond
dans leur vie de tous les jours ne va
pas comparer ce passé là concernant les
jeunes la question de l'emploi est
importante la question de la formation
est importante mais ya pas que ça il ya
un grand malaise quand même la jeunesse
française
on le dit souvent ces jeunes qui ne
votent pas qu'ils se passionnent pour la
politique mais qui ne votent plus qui
est qu'est ce qu'elle devrait faire
qu'est ce qu'elle doit faire quelles
sont les grandes actions les grands
points de préoccupation que selon vous
elle devrait avoir à l'égard des jeunes
français je pense qu'il ya deux ou trois
peut-être dimension il ya une première
dimension qui est la question de
l'intégration politique citoyenne de
l'un d'eux un jeune haïtien soucis dans
notre jeunesse ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
ne se reconnaissent plus dans le système
politique qui ont le sentiment que cette
classe politique ne leur parle pas c'est
un sentiment subjectif parce que on peut
pas dire non plus que les politiques
n'ont fait aucune proposition sur la
jeunesse pendant la campagne
présidentielle ils ont tous fait des
propositions dans ce domaine là meilhan
premier souci citoyenneté intégration
sociale deuxième souci la question de
l'intégration du professionnel il ya
toujours du chômage des jeunes il ya
toujours un souci il ya des progrès de
l'apprentissage qui ont été faits mais
une bonne partie ainsi compris qui est
dans les facultés qui en études et cas
le sentiment d'avoir un horizon qui est
bouché qui sait pas très bien vers quoi
vous mener les études qui a le sentiment
aussi d'une société française où
beaucoup de choses sont tenus par les
seniors et qu'il leur fallait pas assez
la place donc voilà au moins deux des
dimensions sur laquelle elle est très
attendue par la jeunesse
hervé gattegno vous partagez ce ce
sentiment moi je pense que les deux
préoccupations principales des jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est le travail qu'est ce
qu'ils vont devenir laquelle quelques
arrière ils vont vont accomplir l'avenir
après leurs études quel avenir et puis
un sujet qui est aussi une façon
d'envisager l'avenir c'est la
préoccupation écologique qui est
beaucoup plus important chez revenir
dans les autres catégories de la
population force est de constater que
sur ces deux sujets là elisabeth bornes
elle a une très grande compétence être
compétent techniquement et vous disiez à
juste titre que on se fiche un peu de
savoir si elle et techno ou pas ce qui
est important c'est de savoir si elle
est compétente et tout le monde le
reconnaît simplement elle est compétente
mais elle est aussi décidé elle a une
forme d'autorité c'est à dire que ce
n'est pas le genre de femme elisabeth
board qui va écouter tout le monde pour
se faire un avis elle va écouter tout le
monde pour essayer de les convaincre que
la politique qu'elle souhaite mener est
la bonne moi je crois que les jeunes ce
qu'ils veulent pour s'intéresser à la
politique c'est qui est de moins en
moins de démagogues aux postes de
décision et je crois qu'elle isabelle
borne n'est pas une démagogue on la
voyait là tout à l'heure derrière vous
avec le conseil des ministres est-ce que
ça a été une bonne élève dans le
gouvernement est-ce que emmanuel macron
l'a choisi parce qu'au fond il savait
qu'il n'aurait pas de problème avec elle
ben oui bon élève je ne sais pas si et
si celle entre guillemets terme en tout
cas c'est une femme extrêmement sérieuse
elle est très travailleuse et une
dévoreuse de dossiers et on voyait
d'ailleurs niveau comme emmanuelle rol
leurs créations dans la laideur peut
elle était déjà un peu premier ministre
c'est à dire que l était multi
compétente sur beaucoup de sujets
différents elle a des réponses des
réponses sérieuses des réponses
techniques et le fait est que un
prochain président choisit toujours un
premier ministre aussi parce qu'il sait
qu'il est rassurant et que donc ça va
bien se passer avec elle bruno cautrès
hervé gattegno nous avons sur ce plateau
un ancien jeune journaliste dans le bon
sens du terme qui a une journaliste dans
la circonscription d'elisabeth bornes là
où elle est candidate oui à vire dans le
calvados et indiqué nages où j'avais
j'avais j'avais pas 30 ans n'avait pas
30 ans donc c'était hier mais c'est
cette circonscription s'était aussi
lancé l'ancien ces transcriptions
d'olivier sting des politiciens qui
avait été ministre dans gouvernement
rocard au gouvernement barque était
passé de droite à gauche de gauche à
droite qui était un peu un peu comme ça
au centre et surtout et surtout elle
revient dans le calvados les pas
parachutée elle revient tout simplement
sur la terre de sa famille c'est sa
maman ses grands-parents ses arrière
grands parents étaient originaires de
livarot et l'île arros et bien normand
et c'est bien dans le calvados et son
grand père on le voit son grand père et
fille qui s'appelait marcel le scène il
était maire et conseiller général de
livarot c'était le pharmacien de livarot
l'île arros et pour les téléspectateurs
ces mêmes endroits où il ya le fromage
c'est ici où là c'est le fromage porte
le nom de la commune comme qu'à manger
parce des régulateurs étrangers oui nous
regardent de l'étranger voilà voilà
exactement alors son grand père était le
pharmacien pendant la guerre en 1944 il
ya même une anecdote en 1944 romel se
fait mitrailler
à livarot et donc est gravement blessé
et alors on cherchait désespérément un
médecin et on va voir le maire de la
commune qui était le pharmacien qui le
grand le grand père d'elizabeth bornes
et qui a apporté les premiers soins au
maréchal rommel donc dire qu elle est
parachutée et qu'elle arriverait dans un
pays inconnu c'est un peu fort de café
quand même bruno cautrès et hervé
gattegno sont nos invités ce matin pour
analyser les premiers pas à matignon et
qui est également isabelle borne et
c'est une tradition dans cette émission
messieurs show nuque et collaborateurs
et dessinateur de ouest france
françois-xavier le franc le connaît bien
s'est intéressé à notre nouvelle
première ministre
on regarde ensemble ce qui nous a
dessiné en anglais
bonjour il ne suffit pas de se présenter
dans la circonscription wind et michel
drucker pour acquérir la longévité
elisabeth borne est la deuxième femme
nommée première ministre dans l'histoire
de la vème république mais celle
pourrait battre le record d'élite
cresson qui n'est resté que dix mois à
matignon la bataille de normandie a
commencé pour notre première ministre et
les mauvaises langues disent que c'est
une parachutée pourtant son grand père
fut maire de livarot pas de quoi en
faire tout un fromage et puis les
parachutes font partie du paysage de la
normandie mais c'est la nuque baisse de
jean-luc mélenchon
qu'ils veulent a débarqué et cette femme
polytechnicienne a juré qu'elle ne
battrait jamais en retraite bon la
question que je pose c'est quelle option
à le président de la république en cas
de défaite d'elisabeth bornes moi j'ai
la solution il suffit de rappeler jean
castex après un relooking complet
je peux vous dire qu'il ferait encore
très bien la faire
elle peut se créer sony's et et isabelle
borne ou pas bruno cautrès à pour un
premier ministre dans des périodes
difficiles et la période s'annonce
difficile sur le front économique il n'y
a pas que des bonnes nouvelles sur le
front économique on a des bonnes
nouvelles sur le chômage mais il ya des
mauvaises nouvelles qui vont arriver
donc effectivement c'est toujours dans
l'ordre des choses possibles le poste de
premier ministre ce n'est pas pour rien
qu'on appelle ça l'enfer de matignon
donc c'est toujours possible après
l'équation des discrétions était une
autre époque on on va dire il y avait
aussi il y avait aussi à gauche tout un
tas de deux divisions déjà à l'époque
lorsqu'elle a pris le lorsqu'elle apprit
matignon edith cresson beckham un pierre
bérégovoy omnipotent voilà à me voir
c'est le cac attendait quand même un peu
d'être d'être nommé une succession de
michel rocard qui n'était pas évidente
on veut dire donc c'est un peu une autre
époque mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours dans l'ordre des choses
possibles ans à gaza-ville francs elle
devra tenir le gouvernement c'est une
femme qui a de l'autorité et ça sera
important pour durer en politique est-ce
qu'on peut raisonnablement on rappelle
qu edith cresson intéresser quelques
mois est ce qu'un premier ministre
réservé la présente à bleu menthe
travailler en 9 mois est ce qu'on peut
mener des changements importants pour la
france on de fond est ce que c'est
sérieux ou est-ce qu'il faut pas se dire
prémunissent devoir rester cinq ans il
ya du boulot à faire dans la durée il
faut construire pire avant que c'est
d'autant plus important qu'aujourd'hui
la question de l'évaluation de l'action
publique et de vivre un vrai sujet à la
fois pour le parlement pour les citoyens
et tout le monde sait qu'on ne peut pas
de développer des politiques publiques
et conduire l'évaluation de politique
publique en moins d'un an faut au moins
deux ans pour faire ça hervé gattegno
elle peut avoir des casseroles isabelle
borne où on a tous regardé avant c'est
les produits ce qui sont nommés dit
oudin il leur arrive presque un majeur
personnel due à leur parcours votre
question permet de dire une chose qui
est pas assez souligné je trouve c'est
que elisabeth bornes elle débarque pas
de nulle part elle est ministre depuis
cinq ans sans discontinuer en sport de
l'e3 portefeuille très important est
néanmoins différent donc c'est aussi une
marque de compétences et de confiance de
la part du président de la république et
comme vous le savez il ya la haute
autorité qui se cache la regarde qui
scanne absolument tous les parcours les
patrimoines alors on peut toujours avoir
des petits vices cachés si j'ose dire
mais enfin c'est assez peu probable
s'agissant d'elisabeth bornes et dans la
comparaison avec edith cresson je
voudrais dire une chose c'est que et
discrétion elle s'est fracassé sur la
misogynie ambiante hong a énormément
reculé aujourd'hui dans ce pays on en
est plus là et aussi sur celle des
emprunts prudents parce que elle dans ce
poste là elle a fait preuve par moments
d'une forme de désinvolture notamment
dans l'expression qui n'est pas de
l'amusement d'elisa j'en ai rien à cirer
par ailleurs ce soit xavier lefranc la
une de ouest france à la une de ouest
france et ce matin très européenne
puisqu'on parle de l'europe qui accélère
sur les énergies vertes c'est évidemment
fondamental et puis surtout le choc
géopolitique pour berlin les allemands
qui se rendent compte qu'ils prennent
conscience de leur état de dépendance
extrêmement dangereux à l'égard du gaz
russe il aurait peut-être dû écouter les
dirigeants français qui pendant des
années ont attiré leur attention sur ce
sujet là voilà françois xavier le franc
elle est populaire est là elle va gagner
aux élections législatives alvaro alors
l'élection n'ait jamais fait d' avance
mais alors c'est à vivre les façons de
loisirs mais elle est favori
effectivement elle et je pense largement
favorite elle est soutenue par le maire
de vire enfin parler par les élus locaux
mais jean-luc mélenchon qui a dit ben je
voudrais vite la remplacer c'est une
hypothèse qu'on n'envisage pas oui mais
ça va venir à l'histoire il faut la
gagner il faut que ça se passe pas comme
ça françois-xavier lefranc rédacteur en
chef de ouest france merci dans un
instant armelle le goff directrice de la
rédaction de 20 minutes sera sur ce
plateau a tout de suite
[Musique]
pour jouer armelle le goff merci d'être
avec nous un bon joueur votre confrère
notre co producteur denis carot est à
nice il est directeur de la rédaction du
groupe nice matin il a une question à
poser à hervé gattegno sur le bilan d
isabelle borne
bonjour hervé gattegno elisabeth borne a
été ministre pendant cinq ans
successivement des transports puis de la
transition écologique enfin de l'emploi
comment jugez-vous son action et son
bilan dans ses portefeuilles successifs
eh bien d'abord très bonne question
quand on est premier ministre on est
porteur de tout ce qu'on a fait puisque
je les dis elle a effectivement été mis
sans discontinuer depuis cinq ans ll est
à la manoeuvre sur deux très grandes
réformes qui sont celles de l'ouverture
à la concurrence de la sncf est celle de
la sueur et la diriger et et celles de
l'assurance chômage de réforme qui
aurait été difficile à mettre en oeuvre
qui ont suscité des oppositions dans le
monde syndical ce qui montre que c'est
une femme de dialogue mais c'est aussi
une femme à poigne c'est une femme qui
s'est imposé ses vues et puis quand même
dans son bilan même si elle n'en est pas
directement la responsable il faut
reconnaître qu'elle sort du ministère du
travail avec un bilan sur le chômage qui
est le meilleur depuis très longtemps
dans ce pays donc ça c'est un petit
effet turbo pour elle et puis pas jeudi
mais jeudi prochain celui d'après c'est
laurent berger le leader de la cfdt qui
sera à votre place sur ce plateau on
aura l'occasion de parler de la nouvelle
première ministre et de ses premières
actions avec lui il disait être bornes
la nouvelle première ministre donc était
notre invité le 10 février dernier vous
le savez alors ministre du travail a
affirmé que l'écologie devait être prise
en compte dans toutes les politiques on
les écoute l'écologie ce doit être ça
doit être pris en compte dans toutes les
politiques
et évidemment moi en tant que ministre
du travail ancien ministre de l'ecologie
suis très attentive au développement des
emplois liés à la transition écologique
je leur dis dans la réparation dans le
recyclage on a des jce d'emplois très
important je croise beaucoup de jeunes
punks crée aussi des entreprises
précisément sur tout sur tout le
recyclage le réemploi la réparation
l'écologie l'urgence l'urgence le combat
du siècle a dit emmanuel macron et c'est
le sujet qui l'a mis en haut de la liste
de la fiche démission d'elisabeth bornes
est-ce que vous pensez que les français
finalement sont en accord avec cette ce
ce choix de porter l'écologie comme une
des premières préoccupations de ses
projets de ces prochains mois la régate
et quand on regarde les enquêtes de
pions sur les sujets de préoccupation
des français c'est pas l'écologie qui
arrive en premier c'est le château
toujours à l'aller question on veut dire
la thématique générale du bulletin de
salaire de la fiche de paie qu'est ce
qui reste à la fin du marge l'argent
effectivement ça reste toujours pour les
français un point important beaucoup de
français ont le sentiment que malgré les
efforts qu'ils font le salaire ne
progresse pas il ya un sujet dans la
fonction publique important sur cette
question on sait qu apparemment le point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires va être
débloquée donc voilà il ya tout un sujet
qu'elle a su peser les jeunes alors
l'écologie l'écologie de manière très
générale intervient généralement plutôt
en position numéro 3 2 dans certaines
enquêtes union 3 4 voilà en gros ça
intervient comme un sujet très important
aux yeux des français après il faut
s'entendre qu'est ce qu'on appelle la
préoccupation quand la question
d'écologie si c'est l'idée de dire je
m'inquiète pour l'état de la planète je
vois bien qu'à des soucis de
surconsommation con con j'ai trop de
choses et c'est tout le monde a ce
sentiment par contre ça veut pas dire
forcément être d'accord avec l'idée il
faut que tout le monde change à sa
chaudière exactement qui veulent payer
est-ce que je vais pas passer à nouveau
à côté des valeurs c'est pas le sujet
pardon de l'emploi de ce terme est
pourri par excellence c'est à dire que
ce soit on est taxé d'inaction soi quand
on agit et qu'on met en place et qu'on
demande aux gens de changer leur façon
de vivre du coup ils ne l'acceptent pas
et c'est les bonnets rouges etc les
gilet jaune qu'est ce que vous en pensez
à vous et je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est un sujet très difficile il
difficile d'avoir une action
convaincante mais je dirais que c'est
précisément parce que ce n'est pas la
préoccupation première consciemment des
français que le choix d'elisabeth borne
est intéressant parce que elle a une
compétence technique sur le sujet je lui
ai dit tout à l'heure or aujourd'hui et
c'est l annonce du président de la
république entre les deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle il faut que
cette politique irrigue toutes les
autres il faut que ce soit le
dénominateur commun de toutes les
politiques et donc c'est très utile
d'avoir quelqu'un qui maîtrise le sujet
sur un plan technique pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que les préoccupations et
les priorités écologiques soient
respectées dans toutes les autres
politiques s'étaient a notamment les
poly des choix budgétaires mais aussi
les politiques d'éducation les
politiques de santé et donc de ce point
de vue là la compétence de madame borne
est très intéressante ça ne veut pas
dire qu'elle donnera satisfaction à tout
le monde parce que vous avez raison
c'est un sujet qui heurte énormément de
conservatisme et notamment dans notre
vie quotidienne à chacun c'est très
difficile je dirais qu'aujourd'hui
l'écologie devenu un sujet trop sérieux
et trop partagé pour être confiée aux
seuls écologistes et donc c'est une
tentative intéressante de confier ce
sujet à une femme qui est ingénieur
rappelons le depuis valéry giscard
d'estaing il n'y a pas eu à la tête de
l'état français un ingénieur c'est le
cas de madame dorment sienne sur la
réforme des retraites la réforme dans
les réformes alors certes emmanuel
macron a été élu très clairement en
parlant d'un départ en retraite à 65 ans
pour autant c'est un sujet qui est
extrêmement épidermique comment est-ce
qu'elle va pouvoir gérer ce dossier
compliqué parce qu'il ya déjà eu un très
long débat en france sur la question de
la réforme des retraites avant le coc
vide difficile long très technique et
leur pays que ne l'a pas aidé au cours
affaire qu'avant le vide on est
d'une certaine manière la réforme a déjà
été votée elle est pratiquement sur
trois années pratiquement au fond sur au
bout dans sur les rails 2 de démarrer et
à l'époque c'est cette fameuse réforme
dite systémique c'était de choisir de
changer de manière profonde et
tuyauteries deuxième terreur des
retraites et on se rappelle quand même
que le seul syndicat qui à l'époque
soutient la réforme la cfdt vous aurez
laurent berger prochaine à l'époque dit
que la ligne rouge à ne pas franchir
c'est de ne pas toucher à l'âge de
départ légal à la retraite qui est
maintenant la variable sur laquelle on
va on va travailler donc visiblement ça
va être compliqué qui s'est passé dans
cette antique avec le co vide on a de
très massivement creuser les déficits
les français le savent la politique de
ce gouvernement sera aussi de
sensibiliser les français au fait qu' on
ne peut pas continuer à laisser ouverts
tous les robinets il faudra bien faire
des efforts et il faudra d'autant plus
en faire et notamment ça nous amène au
sujet des retraites qu'il faudra
financer la branche dépendance et ça
c'est un des enjeux je pense que
elisabeth baume s'emploiera à mettre
davantage en avant le financement de
cette nouvelle branche de la sécurité
sociale que de se concentrer de
concentrer son livre pour effet sur la
cohésion de facile à entendre sur le
pouvoir d'achat il ya encore de l'argent
dans les caisses comment on va faire ah
ben il y en a il y en a pas ce qu'on
emprunte donc on va encore creuser les
déficits sur ce sujet bien sûr qu'on va
le faire le président de la république
avait annoncé en campagne des mesures
très rapides en juillet ce sera la
première chose que fera elisabeth bornes
et d'une certaine façon c'est un petit
cadeau politique pour elle parce que
c'est plus facile de commencer une
législature en annonçant des nouvelles
pour le pouvoir d'achat ça va améliorer
les fins de mois d'un certain nombre de
français ça lui sera probablement
crédité et puis ensuite le plus dur
arrivera elle est tout à fait légitime
au poste où elle est on a dit les
observateurs les analyses politiques
peut être vous même qu'elle n'avait pas
été le premier choix des manuels mâcon
ça c'est un très bel enchaînement parce
que je viens de parler du petit cadeau
politique que lui fait manuel macron en
revanche ce qui n'était pas un cadeau
c'est de là voir fait patienter et de
nous avoir fait patienter nous les
français on a sept la ford entre
nichoirs falette catherine votre équité
par lui que je pense qu'il ya vraiment
eu une hésitation et je crois que le
week-end dernier c'est plutôt catherine
vautrin qui faisait la course en tête et
ce sont deux profils moi je ne crois pas
tellement à l'explication droite gauche
ce sont plutôt deux profils différents
madame vautrin c'est une élue locale
présidente de la plus grande métropole
française puisqu'on parle des
territoires dans cette émission c'était
une préoccupation des manuels mac ronde
envoyer ce signal et lui il y avait une
autre vision ce qui était celle
d'elisabeth baume ses compétences
multiples et notamment la priorité sur
l'écologie qu'il voulait afficher je
crois que c'est plutôt ça qu'il a choisi
d'accord oui je crois que tu es trois
premiers ministres d'emmanuel vaincrons
donc c'est la première qui n'a pas été
élu local edouard philippe était maire
du havre le jean castex était aussi
maire de prades voilà de prades donc là
on a une première ministre qui n'a pas
du tout siéger dans une assemblée élue
oh mais c'est là pour gagner on se
présente aux législatives c'est edouard
philippe et jean case alex n'avait pas
fait mais c'est vrai que l'histoire du
histoire du premier choix les politiques
ont le cuir épais ils ont le cuir dur
effectivement sinon pour l d'apparaître
aux yeux des français comme n'ayant pas
été le premier choix c'est un point de
départ qui psychologiquement n'est pas
terrible mais ils ont le cul en même
temps que c'est bien ce que cherche
emmanuel macron d'avoir un collaborateur
qui prouve qu'il ne fait pas d'ombré sur
le plan politique oui bien sûr bien sûr
présent façon c'est un des critères on
l'a très bien portés lors de la
passation de pouvoir avec jean castex
elisabeth borgne a appelé les petites
filles à aller au bout de leur rêve
alors comment est-ce que ça se fait que
la nomination d'une femme à matignon
interviennent finalement si tard en
france au 21ème siècle il ya encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire il ya déjà
beaucoup de progrès qui ont été faits
sur les lois concernant la parité
l'assemblée élue en 2017 était quand
même beaucoup plus paritaires que les
prêts précédente assemblée nationale
mais reste beaucoup de progrès à faire
faute quand même tué le constat qu avant
la nomination d'elizabeth borne à mal à
matignon on avait eu le président sommes
le 1er mm le président de l'assemblée
nationale comme le président du sénat
aube au nom du conseil économique et
social un homme président du conseil
constitutionnel vous pouvez ajouter
votre saisie dans du conseil d'autant
plus pourri par exemple pendant la
campagne présidentielle valérie pécresse
et anne hidalgo avait pu avoir un des
critiques assez misogyne quand même sur
leur façon de mener campagne ou pas
vraiment valérie pécresse un petit peu
au moment de son de son meeting un peu
loupé il faut bien le dire mais mais en
réalité pas tant que ça elles ont l'une
et l'autre fait une mauvaise campagne et
c'est surtout pour ça qu'elles ont fait
un mauvais score bruno cautrès et hervé
gattegno donc analystes politiques la
chercheur au cnrs au cevipof enseignant
à sciences po et avec gattegno
éditorialiste au point et à l'opinion
sont nos invités politiques ce matin
tout de suite la une de nice matin puis
celle de 20 minutes nice matin d'une
carreaux et hector duplex il y a un
instant c'est évidemment top cause tom
cruise qui était hier soir l'invité du
festival de cannes pour la projection
vers le top gun on hervé gattegno vous
avez regardé top gun vous allez allez le
voir le film vous aussi bruno cautrès la
nouvelle version à la spectaculaire et
les images qui ont été promus proposé
pour le move on donne effectivement
envie de rire mais le goff est fan de
tom cruise c'est ça non merci ça qu'on
est d'accord parce que la une de
20minutes s'est lancé sur cannes aussi
c'est pas là et tu n'es pas un événement
quand même qu une palme d'honneur à
forrest whitaker comme oui voilà
formidable merci mon mieux que tom
gauffre directrice de la rédaction de 20
minutes persie partenaires de cette
émission dans un instant slimane
zeghidour de tv5monde est avec nous sur
ces plateaux
[Musique]
bonjour slimane rédacteur en chef à tv5
monde merci d'être avec nous deux
invités bruno cautrès et avec gattegno
continue et d'analyser la présence à
matignon de cette première ministre
elisabeth bornes mais tout de suite nous
allons nous rendre aux antilles à
fort-de-france où cyril boutique et le
directeur éditorial de france antilles
notre partenaire à une question à poser
à bruno que très souvent bonjour vous
nos côtes res concernant les territoires
ultramarins et notamment les antilles
guyane une des premières missions
d'elisabeth bornes va quelque part est
de réconcilier les populations avec le
président de la république contre qui
ils ont massivement
voté contre en s'exprimant au premier
tour pour jean luc mélenchon puis au
second tour pour marine le pen
sur quelles thématiques va-t-elle
pouvoir s'appuyer quels sont les leviers
qui vont me permettre de parler à
nouveau à ces populations
se sont sentis notamment lors de la
crise du colis dont la voix la sélection
souvent voilà on parle de loin c'était
de conserver l'on parle de loin sterk
effectivement il ya eu
la crise coville la question de la
vaccination
toute la difficulté qu'a eue de la
communication entre le gouvernement et
les territoires ultramarins sur la
question de la vaccination obligatoire
pas donc voilà il ya eu effectivement un
gros sujet mais évidemment on ne peut
pas comprendre ça sans prendre en compte
en toile de fond tout est question socio
économique les demandes en matière de
justice sociale qui sont très fortes
aussi d'ordre de respect aussi des
différentes cultures voilà un référendum
qui a eu lui aussi sur la nouvelle
calédonie qui n'a pas qui n'a pas fait
que des heureux on va dire sur sur place
avec un taux de participation qui pose
question donc voilà il faut
impérativement trouver
ce que sébastien lecornu va être
maintenue à ses fonctions est ce qu'il
va y avoir un nouveau actuelle d'une
lettre d un nouveau titre intitulé le
titulaire donc ça c'est une question
absolument fondamental parce qu'encore
une fois on ne cesse de dire d'un autre
pays qu'il faut qu'on fasse ou qu'on
réapprenne à faire lefranc ensemble et
c'est vrai que d'une certaine manière
quand on dit ça on a un peu tendance à
oublier des territoires ultramarins
slimane zeghidour j'ai une question à
vous poser le premier ministre en france
d'habitude considère qu' il ya un
domaine réservé celui de la politique
étrangère et qu'il va au président de la
république alors que la constitution est
plus ambigu sur les prérogatives du
premier str sur cette question avec
elisabeth bornes évidemment on parle pas
d'une spécialiste de la politique
internationale oui c'est le moule campus
dire on a évoqué amplement ses états de
service plutôt honorable mais jusqu'ici
elle a fait de la politique de proximité
aux gérants des problèmes domestiques or
quand on est premier ministre d'une
puissance comme la france qui a des
responsabilités internationales
européennes évidemment elle l'a elle va
peut-être sortir de sa zone de confort
bien sûr on dira toujours que la
fonction transfigure parfois la personne
révèle onel des talents jusqu'ici
inexploité néanmoins la question que je
vous pose c'est que parmi les dossiers
qu'elle doit affronter ce sont par
exemple les sanctions que nous imposons
aux russes dans cette guerre et qui
elles vont avoir des conséquences
domestiques direct qui commence
d'ailleurs le volet ressentir la hausse
des prix l'inflation et demain quand on
aura complètement boycotter de gaz russe
on aura peut-être un gaz qui va coûter 3
4 plus cher comment pensez vous qu'elle
est assez outillé pour affronter ces
bourrasques je crois qu'on peut les
qualifier de bois ce qui nous attend
arrivant gatignon vous dites bien les
choses dans votre question elle va elle
va s'attacher surtout aux conséquences
de ses décisions il faut dire les choses
clairement à ceux qui nous regardent et
qui nous écoutent ce n'est pas elle qui
décidera de la ligne de la france sur un
sujet comme les sanctions contre la
russie à cause de la guerre en ukraine
c'est le président de la république et
puis rappelons quand même qu'il ya un
parlement dans ce pays donc lorsqu'il y
à des sanctions il faut qu'elle soit
votée par le parlement mais la ligne là
dessus en effet ce n'est pas écrit dans
la constitution mais c'est devenu
maintenant la tradition sous la vème
république pour ce qui concerne la
politique étrangère et la politique de
défense c'est le président de la
république qui déterminent les choix
stratégiques les choix politiques donc
elisabeth bande là dessus elle
s'alignera entièrement sur les décisions
qui seront prises à l'elysée et en effet
elle gérera la partie la plus difficile
pour les français c'est à dire les
conséquences et notamment les
conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat
bruno cautrès le premier ministre en
france il a quoi à voir avec la
politique étrangère de la france ils à
avoir normalement parce qu'ils n'en
avaient en charge la ce que dit la
constitution c'est que il conduit le
gouvernement conduit sous son autorité
la politique de la nation et qu'il a à
disposition par exemple les forces
armées et en pratique en pratique en
pratique on sait que c'est la fameuse
théorie dite du domaine réservé la
lettre de des institutions qui place le
président de la mission le général de
gaulle quelques atteint voilà qui place
le président la république comme acteur
fondamental de la politique de sécurité
de défense gardien des intérêts vitaux
du b du pays
la dimension européenne emmanuel macron
joue à domicile sur la question
européenne il ne laissera pas une goutte
à son premier ministre est natif sur
cette question et dans ce schéma qu'elle
est là franck la fonction du ministre
des affaires étrangères les plus
importants plus important dès 2010
affaires étrangères lui porte la parole
du président il représente la france à
l'étranger et c'est vrai que sur des
sujets très stratégiques comme la crise
ukrainienne il y aura des discussions à
trois entre le président de la
république le ministre des affaires
étrangères et la première ministre qui
sera associé de très près à toutes les
décisions qui seront prises mais
l'impulsion viendra toujours de l'elysée
et alors là ça m'amène à vous poser une
autre question les les changements qui
vont affecter le corps diplomatique vous
le savez les nains les plus n'est plus
destiné à jouer le même rôle qu'avant le
corps diplomatique va changer ça veut
dire est ce que le premier ministre le
gouvernement auront encore les commis de
l'état formé par ces deux structures
pour travailler les dossiers et leur
donner les réponses et les formulations
les diagnostics qu'il faut pour agir
plus librement sur le plan international
je ne sais pas ce qu'en pense bruno moi
je crois que oui je pense que c'est le
mode de sélection et de formation qui va
changer mais néanmoins que le quai
d'orsay c'est à dire pour ceux qui nous
regardent à l'étranger le ministère des
affaires étrangères soit alimenté de
nouvelles forces de nouvelles recrues
qui viennent parfois du privé je n'y
vois que des avantages en termes
d'ouverture d'esprit la consanguinité
c'est pas forcément ce qu'il ya de
meilleur surtout comme ce sont des
sujets qui ouvre le qui ouvre le regard
de la france sur le monde donc moi je
crois que l'etat sera très bien faire ça
et et reconstituer très vite une très
bonne formation de ses agents publics
dans le domaine des affaires étrangères
bruno cautrès oui je trouve qu'il faut
situer cette question dans le on va dire
le perspective plus large de l'ensemble
de la réforme de de l'état c'est une
bonne chose au fond qu'on remue un peu
le cocotier de ce point de vue là c'est
vrai que l'idée qu'on rentre très jeune
dans un corps de la haute fonction
publique et qu'on n'en sort plus jamais
est une idée qui heurte un peu le bon
sens l'idée pour la l'idée de
l'administration des changes l'exigeant
qui à part dans le privé qui peuvent
éventuellement revenir dans le public à
l'américaine il ya une dimension plus
politique et des joies vraiment très
politique y compris des grands donateurs
privés du président élu qui se
retrouvent ambassadeur je crois qu'on
n'ira pas jusque là en france une minute
encore une question mais justement si
c'est le cas ça veut dire qu'on va
rentrer dans une rupture avec les usages
qui ont prévalu jusqu'ici c'est à dire
une forte administrations centrales des
diplomates de carrière dont qui rôdent
qui obéissent à certains critères c'est
à dire parler beaucoup de langues
étrangères ayant fait beaucoup de
terrain est ce que cette vous pensez
toujours que cette rupture avec la
tradition est porteuse d'un plutôt d'un
renouveau de l'action diplomatique
plutôt que de son affaiblissement moi je
veux je veux pas faire de procès
d'intention je crois que l'esprit de
cette réforme est bon il faut espérer
que ça s'appliquera bien je pense qu'il
y aura toujours un recrutement exigeant
pour des agents qui ont des fonctions
très important d notamment quand vous
dites parler les langues étrangères
j'imagine quand même que ce sera un des
critères importants pour sélectionner
les futurs ambassadeurs de la france
dans les futurs agents secrets aussi
sans doute oui mais cela ils sont
recrutés par le ministère de la défense
un mot sur elisabeth bornes la femme
elisabeth board s quelle peut être la
chef de la majorité elle l'est de par sa
fonction elle vient d'être nommé premier
ministre est ce que ça peut être
considéré comme étant à son goût vous
qui avez analysé elisabeth bornes on est
on est dans cet entre-deux entre l'eau
et textes de bien sûr un stick elle l
est ne fait hélas erratique elle est
censée être la chef de la majorité parce
que c'est elle qui avec edouard philippe
à sa droite les français lavaux à sa
gauche avec ça est-ce que c'est pas
compliqué comme positionnement l'est
aujourd'hui
avons tous les mercredis répondre oui
donc donc si ça n 6 est en première
ligne dans en termes de responsabilité
devant le parlement mais dans la
pratique et surtout avec le quinquennat
le chef de la majorité c'est évidemment
emmanuel macron et on va le faire très
vite aux élections législatives la
question pour les excuses c est ce qu on
donne une majorité à humaniser un crabe
à elisabeth board non je stresse que le
choix d'elisabeth baume ce sans doute se
révéler un choix de ce point de la juge
judicieux c'est que très vite dans le
mandat des manuels macron tout le monde
va regarder à gauche et à droite si je
puis dire qui va succéder un jour à
emmanuel macron et c'est vrai que de ce
point de vue là si vous aviez eu un
billet vous qui soit à la fois très
politique avec beaucoup de poids
politique avec une forme de très gros
charisme personnel évidemment que tous
les regards se tourneraient vers cette
personne alors que la elizabeth bonne
avec un profil plus techno avec un
profil plus effectivement est bien là la
personne qui porte le programme et les
réformes du du présent dans un public
elle va sans doute évacuer échapper à
cette question parce que je ne doute pas
qu au sein de la majorité il va falloir
effectivement à un moment donné m de
l'ordre parce que très vite les les
appétits vont se réveiller dans la
perspective de 2027 et c'est son groupe
à elle de faire la politique
on parlait avec françois-xavier nos
francs au départ dans cette émission du
profil un peu techno
dont on dit qu'elle qu'elle était issue
est ce que c'est son goût la politique
manche aller à la bataille moi je crois
que c'est son goût d'ailleurs vous savez
lorsqu'elle était préfète de la région
poitou charentes c'est elle même qui a
envoyé son curriculum vitae à ségolène
royal qui était ministre de l'écologie
en lui disant j'aimerais bien diriger
votre cabinet vous savez quand vous êtes
préfet préfète et que vous demandez un
ministre de venir diriger son cabinet
c'est que la politique vous attire
ensuite on leur enlevait tout à l'heure
avec bruno elle est candidate aux
élections législatives
ça veut dire qu'elle a envie d'en faire
et que l'on n'en reste pas des années de
sa vie dans les cabinets ministériels
dans les responsabilités multiples on se
retrouve à matignon si on n'adore pas la
politique voulue prédisait un avenir
après matignon ou pas les deux mois je
lui prédis que si elle fait la sphère
qu'elle s'entend bien avec emmanuel
macron elle a tenu compte tenu de ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur la
question de la succession elle peut
rester cinq ans oui oui non maintenant
après on verra ça fait plusieurs
premiers ministres qui dure plusieurs
années vers la à l'époque n'est plus du
tout avec le mandat de cinq ans l'époque
ne permet plus du tout d'avoir trois
premiers ministres par exemple dans un
dans un mandat donc elle va durer quand
même ou au minimum au minimum deux ou
trois ans pour une seule adresse
chercheur au cnrs au cevipof et
enseignant à sciences politiques merci
d'avoir été notre invité et hervé
gattegno éditorialiste au point et à
l'opinion vous retrouve sur les antennes
d'ailleurs aussi de lci de temps en
temps merci à hervé gattegno merci
slimane zeghidour d'avoir été avec nous
pour commenter donc les premiers pas d
isabelle borne et puis surtout son futur
à matignon pour là on se retrouve
évidemment jeudi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro de face aux territoires
merci à vanessa chala rédactrice en chef
de cette émission pascal quentin qui
coordonne la production à nicolas renard
qui dirige la production de cette chaîne
gilles allemand qu'il a réalisé et
thierry barbedette qui a coproduit avec
télé 60,18 cette édition merci et au
revoir à tous les programmes continus
sur tv5 monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]